I have a piecewise defined function here,
and my goal is to figure out its domain
and its range. So first let's think about the
domain.
And just a bit overview, the domain is
the set of all inputs
for which our function is defined.
And over here, an input variable
is x, so to think about, it's the set of all
the values that x can take on,
and actually have this function be defined,
and actually figure out what f of x is.
And when we look at this, we see, okay, if 0 is
less than x is less than or equal to 2. We're
in this clause, it's x crosses 2 and it is greater than 2.
We follow this clause
As we approach 6 but right when we get
to 6, we fall into this clause right over here,
all the way up to and including 11.
But if we get larger than 11, the function is
no longer defined. I don't know which of
these to use.
And if we're 0 or less, the function is
longer defined as well.
So in order for this to be defined, x has
to be greater than 0 or if we say 0 is less
than x,
and you see that part right over there.
And x has to be less than or equal to 11.
and x has to be less then or equal to 11.
It's defined for everything in between.
As we, as we see, once again,
as we get to 2, we're here.
As we cross 2, between 2 and 6, we're
here, and at 6, from 6 to 11 we're
over here. So we're defined for all real
numbers in this interval. So our domain is --
actually let me write this all, all
real values, are all real
all real values. maybe --
Let me write that way.  All real value such
that, such
that, 0 is less than x, is less than
or equal to 11.
So now think about the range.
Let's think about
the range of this piecewise
defined function.
And that's a set of all values that this
function can actually take on.
and this one is, is maybe deceptively
simple because there're only three values
that this function can take on.
You can take on, f of x can be equal to
1. It can be equal to 5,
or it could be equal to negative 7.
So the range here, we could say that f of x
needs to be a member of,
this is just a fancy
mathy symbol, just to say this is a member of the set
1, 5, negative 7. f of x is going to take,
is going to take on one of these three
values. Another way to say it
is that f of x is going to be equal 1,
5 or negative 7. This is maybe a little
less -- a little -- a less
a less mathy way, a less precise way
of saying the same thing. But one way
or another, f of x can only take on
one over these three values.